[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur aux
chaînes de la tnt en région voici tout
de suite les titres de l'actualité
un monde plus vert l'événement de la
semaine c'était le forum nouveau monde
forum de la transition environnementale
et sociétale qui s'est tenu à
montpellier nous entendrons dans ce
journal la vice-présidente du groupe la
dépêche marie-france marchand-baylet
partenaire de l'événement visiblement
très soucieuse de ces questions vous
entendrez également le récit des
aventures rocambolesques du navigateur
guirec soudé tout juste rentré d'une
traversée de l'atlantique à la rame et
oui des péripéties qui ne manque pas de
rebondissements vous le verrez dans un
instant le tiger woods des maternelles
sera dans ce journal on fera la
connaissance d'un sacré petit bonhomme à
l'âge où les enfants aiment faire de la
balançoire et bien georges lui passe la
plupart de son temps sur un green a
peaufiné son string et puis dans ce
journal un éclairage celui de joseph
arakel vice président de la ligue contre
le cancer qui nous parlera de
l'opération qui a eu lieu le week-end
dernier à marseille
que des munitions au palais des congrès
de montpellier pour commencer ce journal
et pour cause s'est tenue trois jours
durant le forum nouveau monde un moment
d'échangés de débats autour de la
biodiversité de l'économie circulaire
aussi des ateliers étaient également
proposés pour apprendre à bricoler à
coudre des ateliers également de
sensibilisation au zéro déchet ou bien
encore aux risques climatiques
interviewé sur le forum marie-france
marchand-baylet la vice-présidente du
groupe la dépêche partenaire de
l'événement se montre extrêmement
optimiste pour l'avenir
les jeunes les enfants les adolescents
sont très sensibilisés au sujet de la de
la transition écologique c'est eux qui
tape du poing sur la table en disant à
leurs parents ont fait plus ceux ci ont
fait plus cela et je suis quelqu'un de
très optimiste je crois en la jeunesse
absolument et je suis convaincu que
c'est la génération des 15 30 ans qui
veut
qui va faire basculer les choses on
continue dans le vert dans ce journal
avec un avion 100% électrique après la
voiture électrique l'avion électrique je
vous présente velis un avion qui peut
voler 50 minutes en autonomie entre 160
et 180 km/heure à toulouse les élèves de
l'ena qu l'école nationale de l'aviation
civile ont pu le tester un événement
immortalisé par la caméra d'agnès
grimaldi pour la dépêche nos confrères
sur place
mais on est assez fiers d'être les
pionniers
donc les premiers veut lever lycée les
nec pour ses importants pour les nex
important pour l'industrie donc on est
on est baigné là dedans et on joue le
jeu voulait sur le v10 je vous le disais
dans les titres de ce journal après le
verre le rose et octobre rose comme vous
le savez peut-être c'est le mois
d'octobre qui est consacrée à la
prévention contre le cancer du sein
partout en france tout au long du mois
des animations sont organisées par la
ligue contre le cancer comme à marseille
par exemple où le groupe mulet que tu as
donné le temps pau face à saint ferréol
et justement nous avons joint par
téléphone joseph arakel le
vice-président de la ligue 13 l'antenne
marseillaise de la ligue contre le
cancer il revient notamment sur
l'importance du dépistage et le
dynamisme de l'association écoute et
joseph arakel alors ce championnat bien
parce que si c'est une ligue qui est
innovante créée aussi je dois son
président pierre leca rosie donc cette
maison du bien-être qui accueillit ide
en 2010 6 6,5 car non vraiment cette
cette nouvelle image de la vie que pour
être plus proche et déjà je suis arrivé
avec ce qu'on a on arrivera le lin que
qu'en prouvant que les délégués des
solutions médicales ce que je veux
vraiment appeler si cette relation de
confiance le doit être totale est on sûr
que nous sommes au service des malades
et uniquement 6 4 voilà sur votre écran
s'affiche à l'instant la bresse à
laquelle vous pouvez faire vos dons à la
ligue contre le cancer n'hésitez pas ils
ont un de vos
tout à fait autre chose dans ce journal
première récolte au mont-dol à nouveau
20 h à redonner il verra bientôt le jour
et natacha store est clair villalon de
tvr à rennes ont pu assister aux toutes
premières vendanges dans ce cépage né il
ya à peine deux ans regardez ce
reportage
sur le mont dol à côté des champs de
maïs un vignoble prend racine côte du
moulin c'est le nom de ce chardonnay une
aventure folle lancé en 2019 par une
association de passionnés et pour
exploiter la parcelle de 1000 mètres
carrés il a fallu beaucoup de travail on
a creusé à la barre à mine et à la main
pour faire les trous pour mettre les
mettre les pieds voilà bien tassés mais
de la paille sous la bâche au pied du
moulin mille pieds de vigne pousse
l'endroit est idéal
nous sommes sur un rocher et va essayer
de se frayer un chemin à travers cette
roche nous sommes sur une pente
extraordinaire vous pouvez le voir en
bretagne il ya quelquefois un peu de
pluie et c'est vrai que la vigne par
définition n'aime pas tellement l'eau
donc ici on n'aura pas ce problème là il
aura fallu près de deux ans à
l'association mont dol 2020 pour monter
le projet et obtenir l'autorisation du
ministère de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui l'équipe de bénévoles
récoltent les quelques grappes de raisin
mais il faudra attendre 2022 pour
déguster la première cuvée bon là il ya
quelques grappillons bon bah je pense
que dans un an ça sera nettement plus et
on va vendanger on va on va faire le vin
alors que les systèmes de vinification
que je connais pas trop même si j'ai
quelques idées sur le sujet enfin bref
c'est c'est un beau projet je crois ce
qu'il faut ce terrain et la cinquantaine
d'amateurs combien fabriqués entre 500
et 700 bouteilles dès l'année prochaine
direction bordeaux maintenant question
comment lutter en même temps contre le
gaspillage et la précarité alimentaire
des étudiants va tout simplement avec un
réfrigérateur zéro gaspillage comme
celui installé au sein de l'université
bord de montaigne ou germain michelet
pour télé 7 la chaîne du groupe sud
ouest s'est rendu pour nos
yaourts
les pattes des fruits mais aussi du
dentifrice et du café c'est une partie
de ce que l'on peut trouver dans le
frigo 0 gaspille de l'université
bordeaux montagne inauguré ce mercredi
chaque étudiant peut venir s'y servir
gratuitement à sa convenance juste
sportive est fait et j'ai un gros
appétit et du coup j'ai pas toujours à
manger à hauteur de ce que de ce que je
voudrais et d'avoir quelque chose qui
est accessible en libre-service ou même
pour très peu cher c'est quand même une
aide en plus le frigo est mis à
disposition sur le campus en
libre-service 7 jours sur 7 et 24 heures
sur 24 les dons alimentaires proviennent
de sources diverses étudiants
associations distribution et autres
commerces le frigo 0 gaspillé composé
d'un dinar marc frigorifique pour les
arbres pour les produits frais et pour
les produits secs
un garde-manger et aussi des produits de
premiers d'hygiène de première nécessité
déjà importante avant la crise sanitaire
la précarité étudiante s'était encore
plus développée pour pouvoir manger
certains avaient dû trouver des
alternatives comme les lire j'ai vendu
des affaires qui enfin mes instruments
de musique mam et consoles gérant du
club truc que j'avais dit que j'avais
depuis tout petit et parce qu' il
fallait que je mange et pas gelé
rachèterait être dans dix ans
c'est pas un petit frigo comme ça qui
peut résoudre le problème de tous les
étudiants enfin c'est un petit plus et
j'espère que ça servira à toute la fac
un petit plus qui va donner un coup de
pouce aux étudiants les plus précaires
l'association du crepac envisage de
généraliser ces frigo solidaire à tous
les campus de la région nouvelle
aquitaine le prochain sera inauguré à
bordeaux sur ce gros courant octobre
et actions la bretagne à nouveau dans ce
journal comme je vous le disais en titre
un exploit maintenant nous est compté
celui de guirec soudé à jeunes
navigateurs de seulement 29 ans il a
écouté bien traverser l'atlantique à la
rame un périple de 5000 kilomètres loin
d'être une sinécure comme il l'a
expliqué au micro de valérie leroux
coléno de tébéo la chaîne du groupe le
télégramme à son arrivée au port du
château de brest
pour accueillir le rameur costarmoricain
c'est toute la panoplie de la marine à
moteur à vous à la foule qui était de
sortie dans la rade de brest d'abord
remorqué guirec a ressorti les rames
pour faire symboliquement son entrée
dans le port sur le quai beaucoup de
gwenn ha du de bravo crier beaucoup
d'émotion et d'admiration je suis ses
aventures sur les réseaux sociaux et que
j'avais encore jamais eu l'occasion de
le voir en vrai après 107 jours de mer
20 heures de rame par jour le marin
était surtout content d'arriver sain et
sauf et d'arriver en bretagne j'ai une
idée
[Applaudissements]
que l'émotion mais si cela n'était pas
gagné car après 70 jours de traversée
des vents contraires l'empêchent de
rentrée et le marin ne cesse de dérivés
donc décidé de faire du sud-ouest donc
partir un peu à l'opposé de la bretagne
je m'écarte et je m'écarte est l'agent
lui j'ai vraiment galéré g1000 24 jours
à tourner en rond à récupérer mon point
gps mais j'étais tellement heureux parce
que pour moi arrivé en irlande en
espagne mais j'aurais dû recommencer en
fait c'était
si monique sa fidèle poule n'était pas
de la partie guirec avoue s'être fait
beaucoup de nouveaux compagnons pendant
la traversée suivi par des requins
blancs j'ai eu des offres j'ai eu des
baleines j'ai eu des étoiles filantes
arts à gogo des moments magiques qui
l'ont aidé à tenir dans cette aventure
plus longue et plus éprouvante que prévu
le marin s'est fait de grosses frayeurs
comme ce moment dans la tente d'une
tempête tropicale
et là je me suis retourné j'ai rien vu
venir je me suis retrouvé à l'envers et
l'eau a commencé à rentrer rentrée
j'avais j'avais plus d'air dans mon
bateau je me suis retrouvé à l'envers
avec mes affaires qu'il partait à bord
plus rien ne fonctionne les vivres
commencent à manquer s'il apparaît
souriant et bronzé aujourd'hui guirec
soudée a perdu 14 kilos mais comme un
breton il a tenu bon à courage s'est
levé sur le quai par eugène riguidel ses
proches évidemment voilà l'aventurier à
terre et ses proches comme beaucoup de
bretons jean pierre et rassurer
et dans ce journal nous partons
maintenant pour le pas de calais à la
rencontre d'un ancien enseignant qui a
décidé de changer de vie et de devenir
brasseur c'est le récit d'une
reconversion réussie par caroline
fichten de wéo la chaîne de la voix du
nord
opération concassage ce matin chez eric
wasser cette ancienne enseignante devenu
brin sort s'élancer en 2018 il a aménagé
son garage investi dans du matériel et a
fait le grand saut de la reconversion
professionnelle basée sur une passion
que la passion les venues
par le biais de mon beau-fils séduit et
brasseurs aussi forte en discuter voilà
le petit virus est arrivé une fois qu on
tombe dedans et je pense qu'on a du mal
à en sortir et puis bon bain ras-le-bol
de
de l'enseignement envie d'autre chose
pour passer à autre chose il a fallu un
peu de temps car on ne s'improvise pas
brasseur vous avez vu tout à l'heure le
concassage là je suis en train de faire
l'empaquetage c'est à dire que je mets
mes céréales concassé dans l'eau chaude
afin de
récupérer tous les sucres
fermentescibles
des céréales je marque et en formation
après système dit pour apprendre et
donc après des essais pour faire les
recréer les recettes sur du matériel
beaucoup au public la brasserie des
terres d'opale c'est l'histoire d'un
ancien prof qui voulait faire quelque
chose de ses mains qui est tombée sur un
passionné et s'est lancé à son tour
entraînant avec lui son épouse
enseignante une histoire d'aix prof donc
mais surtout deux familles et de passion
voilà dans ce journal vous allez voir
tiger woods n'a qu'à bien se tenir tout
comme le champion américain george a
tenu son tout premier club à l'âge de
deux ans et aujourd'hui à seulement
quatre ans c'est le plus jeune licencié
du golfe isabella de plaisir dans les
yvelines portrait d'un très jeune
passionné signé beach and temeria sort
si stéphane pour télé 78 qu'est-ce qui
t'apprend à jouer au golf
a pas une passion de père en fils à 4
ans seulement georges est le plus jeune
licencié du golfe isabella de plaisir
une histoire avec les clubs qui a débuté
il ya presque deux ans ça faisait un
enfin un peu moins d'un an et six mois
qui avait démarré et donc il ya eu cette
période de co vide où on était tous à la
maison et là bas pendant les après midi
lorsqu'on était enfermé bas j'ai sorti
un club est vraiment j'ai remarqué que
george a été très attiré il tapait avec
moi pratiquement tous les midis incident
et des balles pour faire et ceux des
petites s'approche pour françois son
père georges a déjà les qualités pour
faire de lui un futur bon golfeur et ce
même en temps de pluie je trouve qu'il
est et reste très concentré parce qu'ils
apprécient vraiment ça ils sont
objectifs et quand il tape une balle
c'est nous montrer qu' il a réussi donc
les très cher lorsqu'il a réussi à taper
laval et après vraiment essayé de la
rentrée jusque dans le trou et il reste
très patient donc ça s'est vraiment bien
et c'est aussi autre chose c'est que
quand il rate un coup il arrive à se
reconcentrer dire c'est pas grave je
vais réessayer une deuxième fois tous
les dimanches l'apprenti golfeur vient
sur le domaine de plaisir soit pour
jouer avec sa famille soit pour
renforcer ses bases lors d'un cours de
45 minutes georges a été a été licencié
l'année de ses deux ans a au cours de sa
deuxième année là il a démarré à deux
ans et demi et et on a grand plaisir à
le compter parmi nos effectifs
effectivement notre plus jeune pousse et
ça prouve à tout le monde qu'il n'ya pas
ya vraiment pas de limite pour que pour
commencer le goal
contrairement à d'autres enfants du club
il a il a moins déjà besoin de ses
parents pour aller tout de suite en
cours en fait il est il espère motiver
il pas trop timide georges a déjà passé
son premier drapeau en cours et
lorsqu'on lui de monde il se voit
poursuivre sa passion pour toute la vie
voilà il était sans doute également lui
aussi un excellent golfeur ça ne vous a
pas échappé le dernier volet des
aventures de james bond mourir peut
attendre vient de sortir sur nos écrans
une avant première exceptionnelle avait
été organisée à monaco et comme vous le
voyez sur ces images prises par fabien
bonne il ya de monaco un show nos
partenaires sur place le prince albert
ii est arrivé au volant d'une sublime
aston martin accompagnée du réalisateur
du film cary fukunaga
voilà manu dibango saviez vous que le
saxophoniste camerounais qui nous a
quitté en mars 2020 avait vécu dans une
commune de 3000 habitants en plein tueur
de la sarthe son passager resté gravé
dans les mémoires de chacun là bas comme
a pu le constater anthony python de
viale mtv sur place nos partenaires
il tenait beaucoup à ce tableau il te
filent à bouvines me le fruit avant de
de partir ses souvenirs michel les
conserve précieusement ce calaisien est
l'un des grands amis de manu dibango
l'icône du jazz michel l'a rencontré en
1992 quand il a souhaité renouer avec la
ville de saint calais je suis très ému
quand on évoque son nom j'ai toujours
aussi son rire dans ma tête c'était une
vedette internationale
mais il était d'une simplicité qui qu'il
faisait tout tout le reste manu dibango
a connu cinq allées à 16 ans par le plus
grand des hasards
son père voulait qu'ils fassent des
études son frère avait à un
correspondant à 5 av et c'est comme ça
qu'il a débarqué ici mais il aurait pu
avoir un correspondant ailleurs il
serait débarqué ailleurs
c'est ainsi que manu dibango a passé
deux ans à saint calais c'est dans ce
collège le collège jules-ferry que le
jeune camerounais commence ses études en
france en 1949 depuis l'ancien dortoir
qui l'accueillait est devenue une salle
de réunion qui porte son nom dans le
fond de la salle son premier saxophone
qu'il a donné à l'établissement
l'objectif c'était qu'il y ait une
rencontre entre les élèves du 21e siècle
et monsieur manu dibango qui a pu
raconter son histoire aux enfants
cette histoire jean-françois le
professeur de musique du collège
continue de la raconter une façon de
partager avec ses élèves quelques-uns de
ses beaux souvenirs comme son invitation
pour un concert à l'olympia j'ai assisté
à tous c'est à dire que j'ai assisté à
la journée de répétition réglages de son
ce qu'on appelle la balance j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir écouter le choeur de
gospel de londres et puis tous les
artistes qui l'a ensuite invité ce soir
là et évidemment son concert était pour
moi j'étais comme un enfant avec les
lumières dans les yeux et on a bu un
coup ensemble et c'était vraiment
quelque chose de mémorable tout au long
de sa vie manu dibango est revenu
régulièrement dans sa ville d'adoption
de saint calais
et puis aussi à noter dans ce journal le
magazine le point qui sortent deux
éditions cette semaine locale l'une à
lyon et l'autre à toulouse vous le voyez
sur cet écran tout d'abord l'édition
toulouse du point avec ce titre ce qui
se mijote c'est un dossier coordonné par
valérie fr il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
papier dans cette édition sur le bien
manger un tour d'horizon des initiatives
locales également sur 2022 passé par le
capitole c'est une étape capitale et
puis aussi la présidentielle l'occitanie
la bo de campagne d'anne hidalgo et puis
la littérature avec christian authier
qui chante une ode à sa muse enfin les
carnets d'adressés de la rentrée pour
toulouse et ses environs est également
un dossier très intéressant sur
l'immobilier au plus haut donc l'édition
toulouse du point cette semaine et puis
vous voyez sur cet écran également
l'édition lyon avec ce titre ce qui se
mijote un dossier coordonné par audrey
emery au point avec l'institution bocuse
de nouveau au firmament avec un point
d'interrogation un article très
intéressant sur cette icône lyonnaise et
puis les tables la sensation de la
rentrée à lyon un caviste aussi avec un
repaire de bonne cuvée et puis toujours
la politique abordés dans cette édition
locale avec l'opposition le retour de la
droite à lyon enfin un dossier sur les
valeurs sûres de l'immobilier qui
s'assagit donc l'édition locale du poids
à lyon cette semaine
voilà lire c'est aussi voyager disait
victor hugo alors rien étonnant de
découvrir une librairie dans d'anciens
wagon de train un lieu chargé d'histoire
que nous font visiter jérôme errants et
michaël joly devient 95 dont confrères
dans le val d'oise
des bouquins dans des tiroirs de drôles
de sièges des étagères étroite la
caverne aux livres c'est une librairie
insolite dans des wagons et une halle à
marchandises qu'ils croisent les voies
de la gare d'auvers sur oise un projet
un peu fou initié en 1989 par philippe
ferry là c'est du journalisme son fils
s'en souvient bien au départ et vous
voulez quelque chose de très très grands
ils voulaient spectre dans les champs
malheureusement s'est rendu compte que
dans les champs veillerai personnes qui
passeraient donc on a trouvé cette halle
à marchandises et on a rajouté trois
wagons qu'on a fait venir deux de la
gare du nord il ya 30 il ya 30 ans
racheté par la ville en 2017 deux des
trois wagons en jaune à l'origine ont
été repeints en bordeaux en 2020
un moyen de retrouver la couleur
historique de ces fourgons postaux sncf
d'avant guerre antoine cherry a été
témoin de ce changement depuis une
quinzaine d'années il a repris l'oeuvre
de son père disparu j'ai fait la
librairie à
ma façon à moi alors que lui c'était
beaucoup d'ésotérisme et beaucoup de
livres religieux religion cuisine
animaux voyage le public peut trouver de
tout parmi les dizaines de milliers de
livres en vente une variété qui attire
jusqu'à patrick poivre d'arvor l'ancien
présentateur du jt de tf1 vient au moins
une fois par an faire ses emplettes en
plus de l'exhaustivité les personnes
apprécient aussi et surtout l'ambiance
en général lorsqu'elle rentre en disant
c'est extraordinaire c'est cependant on
se croirait je suis harry potter enfin
bon plein de réflexions combien vous
avez livre enfin les gens en général
sont enchantés pour alimenter cette
entre antoine chéri achète on reçoit des
dons suite à des déménagements ou des
décès
l'un des deux derniers bouquinistes du
val d'oise espère susciter des vocations
chez les jeunes générations
voilà partons en pleine nature
maintenant pour avoir la chance
d'entendre le brame du cerf alors il
faut non seulement de la patience mais
aussi de la persévérance et norbert l'aï
ce passionné de séries des normandes pas
vous allez voir comme ont pu le
constater aurélie colombelles et hélène
le plat pour vos jeux télévision
regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en forêt le brame du cerf se fait
entendre l'automne sonne la saison des
amours l'occasion pour norbert laïs de
s'approcher des cervidés sur les
hauteurs du valtin il a remarqué leur
passage dans les forêts du monde des
flaques de boue des traces de dents
et puis on regardera vers les tracés du
cerf parce qu'on leur part les traces
d'ergo comme le sanglier le vidéaste
décide donc de positionner une caméra à
proximité
il récupérera son matériel plus tard en
attendant il cherche un autre endroit
pour se poster avant la nuit déjà faut
prendre ça va cogner le terrain savoir
d'où viennent les animaux pour pas été
surpris je sais que ça va venir par là
j'attendrai d'abord bras mais au fond là
bas après ce sera ici prix monteront
quand il a de la chance ce passionné de
nature rapporte ces trésors chez lui pic
noir faux concert ils postent tout sur
chasse dit mme sa chaîne youtube le
vidéaste a atteint jusqu'à 40000 vues
par jour grâce à des admirateurs de la
forêt vosgienne y compris en inde ou aux
amériques je suis né près de la forêt
j'ai toujours dit que j'ai toujours vécu
en forêt quasiment déjà car je
travaillais
quand je travaillais j'arrivais à être
700 heures en forêt par an ce n'est pas
dans le brahms et c'est plus je pars le
matin je reviens le soir où je parle le
soir j'aurai à lendemain cette nuit là
la patience ne paie pas seuls quelques
cris du brahms entendent au loin
mais le cerf reste à distance la
pression de la chasse qui fait qu' il ya
beaucoup moins d'animaux jetons mais
pour moi encore atteint je trouve qu'il
ya beaucoup moins d'animaux il en faudra
plus pour décourager norbert laïs
surtout que son piège vidéo lui a été
beaucoup plus chanceux
voilà il pourra refermer ce journal un
hommage à bernard tapie décédé le 3
octobre dernier d'un cancer il n'était
pas seulement un homme politique mais
également un acteur et en avril dernier
pour une émission qui s'appelle alain
delon face au monde que j'ai eu la
chance de présenter j'ai assisté à un
échange entre lui et à l'inde donc il
avait vu jouer sur scène regardez et
écoutez cet échange entre les deux
hommes
lorsqu'alain de long est venu vous voir
au théâtre vous jouiez vol au-dessus
d'un nid de coucou et vous aviez une
performance théâtrale qui a impressionné
le public
cgt parce que en fait que tu aies cacher
sa voix
pour entrer par la loge vous souhaitez
je suis seulement content du jeu
penchait décante après il en a parlé
gentiment à 10 ans des choses qui court
depuis quand je décris c'est parce que
sept contre huit heures de nature etc en
plus un tentateur c'est comme si on y
était entré dans la loge
à jouer donc j'ai pas touché de cette
démarche voilà pour l'acteur mais
bernard tapie était également
propriétaire du groupe la provence il
avait accordé une longue interview au
journaliste du quotidien en juin dernier
dans laquelle il faisait le bilan d'une
vie interview de bernard tapie dans la
provence écoutez j'ai l'impression que
je suis pas née pour rien
tu vois voilà si tu veux savoir quand je
lis qu'il courrier quand je vais dans la
rue
je le dis tu as bien fait d'être là
quand je meurs je suis et serai là pour
moi je vous regarde et
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
sur tv5monde et sur vos chaînes
régionales de la tnt on se retrouve très
vite pour une prochaine édition au
revoir à tous et bon courage
[Musique]